Mesela ben burada da selamlar
müzik şölenine geçmeden önce
biraz denemek istiyorum herkes gibi ben
içim biraz kend
imden bahsettim ben Ömer Şener 27
yaşındayım ve bu 27 yıllık ömrün Aslında
21 yılının müzikle geçirdim geçirmeye ve
devam
ediyoruz 6-7 yaşlarındaydım piyano ile
tanıştım aşık oldum sonra lise
yıllarında senaryo yıllarında şarkı
söyleme ile tanıştım ama
Onun bir hikayesini anlatmak istiyorum
çünkü güzel bir hikayesi var oranın
Aslında maalesef 6 yaşından 5 yaşında
13-14 yaşlarına kadar benim tek bir
Lakabım vardı ve inanmazsınız Ama bu
lakap karga sesliydi Çünkü gerçekten
çocuğun bedenine 50 yıllık böyle sigara
içüc
[Müzik]
üsü yaptı telefonlar çalar iyi kokuda
açarım Pardon Emel'i alabilir miyiz
derler beni ölüm adamı
[Müzik]
çok özgüvensizdim ve lise yıllarına
kadar şarkı söylemeyi çok sevmeme rağmen
asla insan içinde şarkı söylemezdim ama
tabi hepiniz yapıyorsunuz
Dur ben de herkes gibi duşta bir
şarkıcıydım ve lise 1 veya evde
bir ev bom
boş hiç bakmayın yanlış 14 yaşında
olduğumu yani
havada uçuyor Sanki o karga sesli
muhteşem sesleri böyle bir toprağınla
bir anda ne oldu Kapı açıldı aralandı
babam kendisi de burada bir anda dedi ki
kızım Radyo çok bağırıyor sesini ve
hemen Sustum anında yerin dibine orada
beni şu Yandık Çünkü biliyorum babam
benimle deli gibi davranacak o karga
sesi ile dalga geçecek Anne ben
anlatacak yetmeyecek misafirleri
anlatacağım
dolayısıyla böyle kıpkırmızı bir domates
olarak banyodan çıktım babam yanıma
koştu hiç unutmayacağım o anı bir anda
bornoza yapıştı böyle dedi ki bir dakika
dedi o şarkıyı söyleyen Yoksa sen miydin
demek istemedim geliyor dalga Kıyamet
diye Evet baba ben de koşturduk telefonu
aldı annemi aradı Yani ben dedi bizim
karga sesi ne olmuş inanılmaz bir sesi
var Ben o zaman öğrendim iyi şarkı
söylediğimi sonra biraz Zaten şu
mikrofonu benim elimden alamadılar
Joseph yıllarında
oturdum şarkı söyledim sonra Fransa'ya
gittim
üniversite sokaklarda şey yapmış demek
istedim geldim Burada Amatör şarkılardan
amatör sahnelerde şarkı söyledim yani
müzik beni bırakmadı Normalde müziği
bırakamadım bugünü biliyorsunuz konsepti
alan açmak alan yaratmak Aslında çok
uygun olduğunu düşünüyorum buraya Çünkü
iyi giden bir toplumsal Kariyerim var
ama işte tutku
müzik Bunlar çok başka şeyler
biliyorsunuz ve Biz birbirimizin peşini
bırakamadık Şimdi de ben yepyeni bir
sektörde kendime yeni bir alan
yarattığım çok heyecan verici bir
dönemin içindeyim Benim Müziklerimi
Meral yer alır gibi çok değerli bir
kendisine başladı Şimdi de bir o kadar
değerli müzisyenle Aykut viral ile devam
ediyor Şimdi biraz böyle ufak ufak
Sizlerin de katılmasını istiyorum bir
klasik seçkisi hazırlamak istediğim için
şimdi devam edelim lütfen eşlik edin hep
beraber söyleyelim
bu
[Müzik]
aşkı Rabia
ben sana ben
Bir Günah Gibi
Gizledim Seni
[Müzik]
kimseye gelmedi
Seninle benim
Ah Gönlüm
ün ardına
[Müzik]
egemde
müzik geldim
uzaktan uzağa
Dertsiz kaldım
[Müzik]
gibi hep beraber
Gizledim hepsini kimse
[Müzik]
Bir Günah yine tekrar geri dön
Mem Bir Günah Gibi
[Müzik]
bize
her gün içim
yandı gözlerim bir gün Nar gibi yeter de
Harikasınız müthiş duyuyorsunuz müthiş
görünüyorsunuz böyle devam
edebilen bir şarkı ile devam ediyoruz
yine sizlerden eşlik etmeyeceğim
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
Ben seninle hiç durmadan tartışırım
ömrümüz gibi
[Müzik]
üstüme gelmene gerek yok
neden yok
[Müzik]
bu işlerde
sen de
yadig
ma
yanar
dağ göz
[Müzik]
den
anlarsına geçmek bunca zaman
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
harika
[Müzik]
yanıldık
[Alkış]
şarkısıyla sonlandıralım hep beraber
söyleyeceğiz Çok teşekkür ederim daha
uzun sahnelerden inşallah
Bu şarkıyı bulmayı çok seviyoruz hepimiz
çok iyi biliyoruz
bomba gibi bir kapanış yapalım hepinize
Tekrardan çok teşekkür ederim
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
her peygamber
[Müzik]
seni ağlata geçmişi senden bir şey yok
yaşamaya
[Müzik]
[Alkış]